hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his article virtue ethics is a
resource for business robert audi is
going to talk about some of the
challenges that people often bring up
not just in business ethics but in
ethics in general
considering how we would work with
virtue ethics is it really practical how
how can we do it and so he talks about
four areas in particular of ethical
challenge he's not saying these are the
only ones but these are the ones that he
thinks are most relevant for business
ethics and he says that one of these is
ethical decision how do we actually
decide things do we do it by saying what
would a virtuous person do in this case
and he says this isn't the only way we
might proceed whether we adhere to a
virtue ethics or whether we operate with
the sense of the importance of virtue
and guiding our con conduct for one
thing
problems of evaluating such
hypotheticals are difficult and the
guidance they provide is limited by our
abilities to anticipate how agents would
be affected by changes of kinds that may
have never occurred you know so saying
how would cato have handled this if
you're a stoic or how would aristotle
himself have handled not always that
helpful and he says that
these hypothetical questions invite one
to proceed beyond the specific you know
person and instance to think about an
abstract understanding of the notion of
a virtuous person or at least one of
more virtues and he says this is this is
good but this may not be helpful in the
situation because the point is as he
says to act from virtue
not from a conception thereof we want to
we want to actually be virtuous this is
a point that aristotle and other virtue
ethnicists have made as well
and then he says you know one
alternative is what we can call a
narrative approach so we consider
imaginary or historically relevant cases
and then we imagine
a role model's resolution rather than
taking like historical figures and
saying let's act exactly like abraham
lincoln did in this case we we think
well what what is the virtue expecting
of us here how would this play itself
out this might be something better done
dialogically as well and he gives a
great example of this with the johnson
and johnson tylenol case if you don't
remember that somebody was poisoning
tylenol johnson and johnson pulled it
off the shelves at great expense to the
company the right thing to do it was a
virtuous action the uh enron case
illustrating some you know particularly
ver uh particularly virtue averse and
definitely
vicious behavior piled on vicious
behavior piled on vicious behavior i
mean in that case the more you probe
into it the worse it is
one thing that was interesting about
that they actually had an award-winning
code of ethics that they didn't follow
at all so
that's a real problem so so ethical
decision that that's one area another is
considering what role the rules of
action play some people think that
virtue ethics means that you don't have
any rules at all you just get into
situations kind of blind and then you
know use your virtues to figure things
out that is a recipe for disaster
no no real virtue ethics actually
teaches that you should do that and so
virtue ethics does have a place for
ordinary rules they may rely on rules at
many different cases and points um they
may include for for example some that
are largely unfamiliar
where the agent has been given credible
arguments supporting some rule for
dealing with them
and
you know as audi points out you really
can't teach virtues you can't encourage
moral development without using some
rules but the goal is not just to stick
with the rules the the you know the
point is to figure out when the rules
actually fit well when they don't and
rules can't tell you that you can make
rules on rules on rules but it's still
not going to solve that problem that's
where the virtues actually come in and a
virtuous person is the person you can
say who can figure out when the rules
apply and to what degree
so you know they they will in fact use
rules but they're not just going to be
relying solely upon them
traits of character grounds of action
this is important as well
he talks about wd ross and ross's seven
prima fascia duties
he says that
you know several of these justice
non-injury fidelity veracity beneficence
self-improvement reparation gratitude of
these terms only three of them fail to
indicate a virtue at the same name and
this isn't because they're not
involving virtues they actually may
involve several so for example
to non-injury
corresponds gentleness kindness and
respectfulness
to self-improvement there corresponds
being self-critical and being proud in
the right way so there's a
correspondence between virtues and
principles we don't have to say ah
principles don't matter at all just
virtues we can use principles
and there's another key thing here
though what do virtues bring if you want
to talk in business terms what is their
value proposition right
well one thing that virtues do
and this is not just audi putting this
out there's many other authors who
point out this this as well for example
nancy sherman in the fabric of character
we'll talk about ethical salience
here audi talks about a person who has
virtues
to have the virtue is in part to be
perceptually sensitive to the relevant
grounds which is a cognitive receptivity
and a behaviorally responsive to them in
the right way which is a matter of
conduct so for example
a just person
somebody who actually has justice isn't
just acting in accordance with it but
has that virtue
is more likely than someone who lacks
this virtue to see cheating that occurs
in fulfilling a contract and to respond
to it with action or at least
disapproval sufficiently strong to yield
action if a sufficiently
suitable opportunity arises right and so
this is actually something that that has
been noted really since ancient times
the virtues make us better able to
perceive what's relevant within the
situation than a person who lacks the
virtues
finally virtues and obligations can
virtues sometimes conflict with each
other yes they certainly can
now if you do ethics for very long
you're going to find that there are very
few moral systems in which there aren't
some conflicts between principles or
rules or whatever it is that you have so
virtue ethics is not unique in that
respect and when we run into a
contradiction we have to say okay what's
going on here
is it that the virtues themselves are
contradictory to each other
probably not
that's probably
a misreading of the case
based on abstractions of the virtues
what really happens is that a person who
has more than one virtue finds
themselves in the particular situation
being pulled in different directions by
the different virtues because of the
complexity of the case so they actually
are virtuous then he says like
you know the person is pulled in
different directions a virtuous person
will have traits of fidelity and
beneficence and so they can face hard
decisions like fidelity to shareholders
and beneficence to employees you know
fidelity to shareholders means trying to
maximize profits uh you know beneficence
to employees means trying to pay them as
much and give them as many benefits as
possible these are not inherently
contradictory unless we decide it's a
zero-sum game but you are being pulled
in different directions and this is
where maybe another virtue like prudence
comes in
we can attain what what audi calls a
reflective balance or a little bit later
a reflective equilibrium a reflective
balance among the div the diverse
inclinations that go with all the
relevant virtues again this is where
prudence may play
an important role he says roughly
speaking reflective equilibrium is a
condition of balance among our general
principles
concrete cases they apply to and related
beliefs and attitudes we may hold so
there may be cases where we have to do
some weighing nobody ever said that
virtue ethics means that you know the
virtues like automatically solve every
situation for you and as he points out
um the same considerations hold for rule
theorists rule theorists are going to
have fewer resources if they don't
appeal to arataic notions that is
notions of virtue so
you can do without virtue ethics if you
want to but you're probably going to
have a harder time
dealing with contradictions that are
inevitably going to arise so these are
four areas of ethical challenge none of
them pose irresolvable challenges but
they do help us to zero in on what
virtue ethics is supposed to look like
in practice in business
you